it's us
I'm tired look it's us
against them this show
came from like
it's the best thing that's ever happened
to me it's the best thing I've ever done
it to be able to do this with my son
Jacob is so crazy but
to see how good it turned out and then
to know that all the execs in town
said no to it is like the best right
this is our chance to show them yo if
you watch TV and you're like why isn't
anything good on TV that's because these
people are out of [__] touch they're
out of touch
they're out of touch
and so this show is for us
Hollywood execs are what they are
but they're not creative people the
creatives don't get into the executive
positions we stay creative
however it's a bunch of executives
non-creatives who are in charge of what
you watch
right and these are not that's why you
see you're like I feel like I've seen
this show like if you might a new show
might come on you're like this
it's like they're 37 yellow Stones now
right because people can be creative
they're like if that works I need 10 of
those
and so
I kept I know the reaction that I get
with me and Jakey
I know I I listen to you all and I talk
to some people and they're like nah
father-son stuff or that family stuff
nobody wants it I'm like okay but
I'm just telling you and so
I learned my lesson when I put out my
special father of the year
which nobody wanted to buy 10 million
views later
and I was like you know what these
people don't know
what other people want to watch
and I at least my fans my crowd I know
what you guys because we talk about it
I'm I'm I listen to what you say and
um I was like [__] it
I'm gonna do this myself because I know
it's gonna be great and I love hanging
with my kids and so I I am a dude who
bets on myself
so I paid for it we shot 10 episodes I
paid for it all
I could lose a lot of [__] money
but I'm betting on the fact that that
this is good
and
I'm betting on you guys because I know
you guys have always
come through for me and I people ask me
all the time how they can support me you
know I don't have a Shopify store I
don't my stuff my YouTube is free I
don't have a subscription page
just watch the stuff that's how you can
support me